hi my name is steven grant between
filming two characters played by the
same actor and creating a hippo goddess
the making of moon knight was a massive
collaborative process which scene
required over 200 extras to film let's
find out okay here we go stand by and
ask me
number one
the moon knight costume is beautiful and
was a result of everyone putting their
heads together to come up with the
perfect design the design of it
was a process uh collaborative process
on the legs of the costume are
hieroglyphics inscribed that translate
to the protecting soldier of the moon
since the word knight did not exist in
the ancient egyptian language they used
fabric that was stretchy enough for
movements but tough enough to survive
all the stunts the partner to munite is
the much more dapper mr knight and his
style makes sense because mr knight is
what stephen
imagines is cool the costume was a
custom three-piece suit and the
waistcoat had unique buttons that had
the conscious symbol on them his
sneakers were adapted to give them a
modern look and straps were added to
resemble the look of a mummy oddly
enough the two characters originally had
their outfits swapped with mark spector
wearing the nice suit and steven grant
sporting the cow but they switched it
after realizing it made more sense the
other way around i feel like steven's mr
knight don't we think that and then
they're like we think exactly we were
thinking the same thing and so then that
got switched number two
the transformation scenes are some of
the most fun and visually awesome of the
entire show we wanted to make sure that
it felt like it was a magical
transformation they wanted the sequences
to feel as if the costume was coming
from the person as opposed to the
costume appearing in a way that feels
disconnected having the real practical
suit on set was a huge help for the vfx
team who used it as reference when
animating the transformations
number three
between kanchu tawedit and ahmet there
were plenty of full cgi characters to go
around the actors were actually filmed
on set and even had real costumes made
for their characters this gave the vfx
team great reference material for when
they animated the full cg character so
it wasn't just guys in grey suits
running around the actors had green
poles extending above their heads to
represent their character's height they
even made a full-scale contour head for
reference on set that had to be fun to
film with
number four
director mohamed diab was adamant about
making his sets as accurate as possible
in order to get a high level of accuracy
a giant set of downtown cairo was built
it spanned about four or five blocks and
green screen lined the outside they had
255 extras on set with 55 picture cars
driving around when i got on the cairo
streets i was so overwhelmed i like had
actual anxiety it was so realistic that
some of the egyptian extras told the
director that they felt like they were
at home
number five
moon knight has some serious fighting
skills so oscar isaac needed to make
sure he properly represented the
character's skill set isaac learned
multiple styles of fighting techniques
and martial arts including boxing
wrestling gymnastic takedowns and
brazilian capoeira isaac also
incorporated weapons into his fighting
and you can see him getting a little too
into it when he lex his knife but that
was for when he was fighting as mark
spector's moon knight fighting as steven
grant was completely different they
needed to choreograph a character who
had no fighting skills which proved to
be a fun challenge that's the most
complicated things to do when you have
to choreograph a fight with someone
story-wise who doesn't know how to fight
but i love that number six
the fight with the invisible jackal
during episode 2 took a lot of prep work
from the stunt team they needed to do a
lot of pre-visual work to understand how
the fight would flow with an invisible
opponent they ended up shooting the
fight scene with stunned people in grey
suits that would push and pull the
actors and perform the fight these
people were later removed with visual
effects as were any wires and mats used
the result was an awesome scene and the
perfect introduction to mr knight
number seven
when you see the inside of the pyramids
on the show that was mostly a practical
set they built and dubbed the chamber of
the gods just how big was it a whopping
three stories tall this is our biggest
set
probably one of our biggest sets if not
the biggest they had two egyptologists
and a researcher to help them make the
set as accurate as possible without
being too cliche it was such a big
undertaking that they had an entire
stone shop of people dedicated to just
making the statues for the sets that is
true dedication to the craft
number eight
another immensely impressive set that
was built was alexander's tomb this set
was 100 practical from the sarcophagus
to the paintings and statues they had
several people from an art school in
budapest come in and paint the chamber
to give it an authentic and accurate
look multiple projectors were set up
that projected the images and
hieroglyphics onto the walls acting as
an outline for the painters to follow
number nine
steven grant's english accent perfectly
suited the character and was so charming
but he originally wasn't going to have
it oscar isaac came up with the accent
and personality of the character at his
house and started doing the voice for
his kids i saw an opportunity to do
something really fun he got some advice
from crew members that were from
budapest in london i could always go to
be like how would you say this what
would you say how do i sound does that
sound okay does that sound okay yeah
mate it's all right
number 10
the museum where steven grant works was
actually the museum of fine arts in
budapest the crew transformed three big
rooms into their own sets recreating the
egyptian section of the british museum
the team made 140 individual pieces that
filled the rooms with the biggest item
being over 19 feet tall the detail in
artwork was truly impressive as they
captured the look of real artifacts in
the museum
number 11
the team behind moon knight put in so
much work and detail into every scene
that you may not have even noticed that
steven's apartment was built for a
specific purpose they decided to make it
an attic apartment because it would
resemble the shape of a pyramid and
steven's bed was made under a platform
as if he was in a sarcophagus being
tuned in the crew's attention to detail
never ceases to amaze us
number 12.
oscar isaac was the perfect choice to
play moon knight and kevin feige had his
eyes set on him from the offset isaac
however had never heard of the character
so he did a deep dive into the comics to
help him prepare for the role it was
very important to him that he take the
mental health aspect of the character
very seriously as he wanted to do a
character study on the complexities of
mark spector and stephen grant
number 13
oscar isaac was watching the good lord
bird and mentioned to director mohammed
diab that ethan hawk would be amazing to
play the part of arthur harrow the same
day isaac ran into ethan at a coffee
shop and mentioned the idea to him a
couple days later they grabbed a drink
together and isaac convinced him to be
in the show it was a very easy yes i
mean i never thought twice about it
number 14
oscar isaac did a lot of research on
dissociative identity disorder because
he wanted to make sure he portrayed it
in the correct way he wound up reading a
book called a fractured mind that he
said ended up being his bible really
gave him some complexity and and really
made him a character that was
fascinating number 15
who is the perfect person to play oscar
isaac's double how about his brother for
the scenes when both mark and steven
were in the same room they brought in
isaac's brother mike hernandez to play
his counterpart so when you see them
talking to each other you're most likely
watching oscar isaac have a conversation
with his bro
the amount of work that went into
creating moonlight is impressive which
behind the scenes fact did you find most
surprising let us know in the comments
and thanks for stopping by at the things
you